I have something that I think you're
going to enjoy today there's a young
woman named Caitlin Bennet who I had
never heard of before yesterday before
seeing the videos I'm gonna play for you
today but apparently she's known as gun
girl in some circles
she's a pro-gun anti-abortion anti trans
seemingly religious conservative she
strikes me as a religious conservative
although although maybe that's not the
case wikipedia says that Bennet received
media attention in 2018 because she
opened carried an ar-10 rifle at Kent
State University imagine being known for
holding a gun holding a gun is what
she's known for
I believe she's 23 24 years old she goes
to college campuses and she does these
horribly bad faith dishonest gotcha type
interviews where she wants to show how
crazy things are on liberal college
campuses and she asks students what do
you think about abortion or what do you
think about guns or trans people it's
done totally out of context and very bad
faith and she did this the other day and
a young man who has upper management
written all over him I think you will
agree after watching this segment
stopped her short when she started
asking Oh what about tampons in men's
rooms or what about this or that and the
kid very clearly says who cares
no one's committing a crime I'm living
my life I believe in individual liberty
who cares about this stuff check this
out how do you think about putting
urinals and women's restrooms for women
who have penises and they just want to
stand and peek I think people just
making too big of fun naughty words okay
so we should or should it I mean I don't
really care okay what about tampons and
pads and men's restroom for men who have
periods if you're really getting that
worked up about it why does matter like
I don't care just sitting there I'm not
gonna take it we should provide men with
tampons I mean if a dude wants a tampon
for some reason he can have a tampon
that's not my business what would he use
it for that's his problem will we use a
pad for his problem do you think they
should seek medical advice if they're
having
I mean if they want to I don't really
care why should I care I care about
people
they're reading out of their penis I
would want to I care about people's
personal rights they can do whatever
they want some none of my business
beautifully done absolutely beautifully
done this is like a fake reactionary
libertarian this woman Caitlyn Bennett
meeting an actual libertarian and I mean
libertarian in the authoritarian versus
libertarian sense not like a capital L
libertarian who says there's no crime
being committed there's no violence to
anyone there's no interference with my
life what do I care about where a tampon
is found she has nowhere to go with it
because she can't get an emotional
response from the student so she has to
become more unhinged and start saying
things like what about a bleeding penis
then here's another one that went
horribly wrong and and she actually is
so unbearable that I almost started
feeling bad for how dumb she looked here
but then I didn't take a look at this
and there's there's there's more than
people think what men having periods
mm-hmm
yeah my god did you tell them to seek
clinical help if men are having periods
trans men have berries okay okay explain
that one to me yeah so us people who
have transitioned from female to male
you know obviously you know they might
still have periods and you know if they
identify as male you know they have the
right to go into the men's room but if
they're still having periods they have
the right to have you know the products
they need this is of course how these
reactionary social conservative
movements work they work by
strategically narrowly framing questions
when it makes sense and then when it's
more convenient you broaden it where the
questions and the topic are way too
broad to actually have any meaning and
if conservative I'm sorry conspiracy
theorists actually do the same thing
there's a strategy in pushing conspiracy
theories where you will sometimes say
let's zoom way out in order to further
your conspiracy theory but when taking a
broad view actually hurts your
conspiracy theory you zoom way in into
narrowly calculated details and it's a
very similar strategy here first they go
very broad something like the identity
politics left thinks men can have
periods ok well it's not hard to
understand if you're born biologically
female you transition to male unless you
have certain procedures you've got a
uterus you have the reproductive system
doesn't go away so someone who
identifies as male in society and uses
the men's room might still have a period
menstruation may still be part of their
biological reality so then they go
abroad and they write that the left
thinks men has pure you have periods or
something like that and then when you
point out how absurd the framing is they
will narrow it - are you telling me you
don't care about someone whose penis is
bleeding
this isn't about a man whose penis is
bleeding this is about individual
liberty
it's about rights it's about nobody's
breaking any laws and the most important
takeaway here because it's an election
year is that these people vote and many
people agree with the framing of Kate
Caitlyn Caitlyn Bennett she gets to vote
the people who find her intelligent and
who find her videos prescient about the
future of America they vote and none of
this means anything if we can't start
fixing this problem from the bottom up
and that means we all have to vote in
November of 2020 I want to hear from you
what do you think about these videos
we'll take a quick break and be back
right after this